am 13 September wird die 22-Jährige
Masse Amini von der Sittenpolizei
verhaftet sie bricht den
Polizeigewahrsam zusammenfällt ins Koma
drei Tage später wird sie für tote
erklärt
mich haben sie auch schon zweimal
mitgenommen ich dachte mir wenn mir das
passiert wäre wie würden sich meine
Eltern fühlen
der zustand ihres Kopftuchs war nicht
vorschriftsgemäß deshalb wurde sie in
ein Polizeifahrzeug gebeten weder sie
noch eine der anderen Frauen haben
Widerstand geleistet sondern sie haben
mit uns kooperiert
viele halten das für eine weitere Lüge
des Regimes es ist der Tropfen der ein
Fass voller Frust und Wut zum Überlaufen
bringt die Lage ist soweit eskaliert
dass das Auswärtige Amt alle deutschen
dazu aufrief das Land zu verlassen
[Applaus]
es sind vor allem die Frauen die sich
auflehnen Tod dem Diktator rufen Sie und
Zaid Ali wird stürzen
[Applaus]
gemeint ist er ah ja toller Ali rameney
iranz religiöse und politischer Führer
Herr über Armee revolutionsgarten
paramilitärische basic Milizen die im
bislang noch treu ergeben sind eigene
Fehler sieht der nicht sucht die
Schulter leihen bei den Feinden im
Ausland die wie er meint iranische
Jugend verführten
diese jungen Leute wurden aufgestachelt
durch solche Videos die im Internet
verbreitet werden
diese Unruhen wurden alle von Amerika
und Israel geplant und von den
iranischen Verrätern im Ausland
[Musik]
das Regime schickt auch diesmal wieder
brutale Schlägertrupps 280 Menschen
sollen bislang getötet worden sein
irans-gesellschaft ist tief gespalten es
stehen sich zwei Seiten gegenüber die
sich völlig entfremdet haben bis vor
wenigen Tagen war ich noch selbst im
Teheran für uns ausländische
Journalisten aus dem Land zu berichten
ist nicht leicht
wir sind wie alle Journalisten
akkreditiert beim Ministerium für Kultur
und islamische Führung genannt erschert
dort müssen wir unsere drehreisen
beantragen doch in Zeiten des Protestes
erlaubt uns das Ministerium nicht die
Hauptstadt Teheran zu verlassen wir
dürfen auch keine Proteste drehen und
keine Interviews mit Protestierenden
machen was uns aber erlaubt wird
problemlos das ist zum Beispiel das
Freitagsgebet zu drehen und die danach
stattfindenden pro regierungs-
wir sind bereit für unseren obersten
Führer unser Leben zu geben schwören die
die vom Regime auf die Straße gerufen
wurden sie sind entschlossen die
Islamische Republik und deren Regeln zu
verteidigen und dazu gehört auch dass
die Frau Kopf und Körper bedeckt
wir Vertrauen in unsere Gesetze und die
islamische Scharia und wir müssen uns
darauf konzentrieren dass diese Gesetze
auch eingehalten werden
Frauen sollten wissen dass dies ein
islamisches Land ist und wir hier leben
will sollte sich an die Regeln dieses
Landes halten
drinnen beim Freitagsgebet in Teheran
wettert ein Mitglied des hohen
Wächterrates der todmaße aminis sei zu
betrauern sagt er doch was ich auf den
Straßen abspiele sei ein Krieg gegen die
islamische Republik
es geht ihnen darum unsere Religion
anzugreifen es geht ihnen darum den
Koran zu verbrennen und Moscheen
anzuzünden und darum das muslimische
Kopftuch abzuschaffen
[Musik]
die aktuelle Protestbewegung sei die
stärkste politische Bewegung seit vielen
Jahren meint der renommierte
Politikwissenschaftler
sie werde von fast allen Schichten der
Gesellschaft im ganzen Land getragen
deshalb herrschte in der politischen
Führung Uneinigkeit darüber wie mit den
Protesten umzugehen sein
Mini Iranian viele hochrangige iranische
offizielle sind bisher auffallend ruhig
geblieben und haben sich noch nicht
geäußert was hat das zu bedeuten meiner
Meinung nach könnte das heißen dass Sie
nicht einverstanden sind mit dem
obersten Führer haben wir nee mit der
Regierung von Präsident raisi und mit
den revolutionsgarten
so meldete sich einer der höchsten
schiitischen Geistlichen zu Wort aja
toller Alavi Boro jerdi einer der
wenigen die sich solche Worte erlauben
können in terosa ich fordere die
offiziellen unseres Landes allen voran
Ali rameney ernsthaft auf zu handeln
unsere Jugend die Studenten die Arbeiter
haben etwas zu sagen gebt ihnen den Raum
sich zu äußern aber das tut ihr nicht
und das Ergebnis seht ihr in den
Aufständen auf den Straßen
das brutale Vorgehen der Sittenpolizei
und der Sicherheitskräfte lehnen auch
viele religiös konservative Frauen ab
viele von ihnen gehen bei den
Demonstrationen selbst auf die Straße
auch wenn das Kopftuch Pflicht ist
sollte es auf keinen Fall in so
unzumutbarer Weise durchgesetzt werden
ich bin weder für noch gegen die
Sittenpolizei aber sie sind sicher ein
Grund dafür dass viele Frauen in Iran
leiden
wir treffen in Teheran die bekannte
konservative Frauenrechtlerin freisea
Chemie sie trägt freiwillig den chador
fordert aber seit langem dass jede Frau
die freie Wahl haben sollte ob sie das
Kopftuch tragen will oder nicht
über 70 Prozent der Menschen in
iranlehnenden Kopftuchzwang ab und über
die Hälfte ist grundsätzlich gegen das
Kopftuch das ist das Ergebnis unserer
Politik wenn es darum geht Religiosität
zu fördern müssen wir einfach einsehen
dass unsere Strategien falsch sind
angeblich so hören wir werde im
Parlament diskutiert die Kopftuchpflicht
zu reformieren es gäbe solche
Initiativen behaupten sowohl
reformorientierte als auch konservative
Interviewpartner die wir enthäre
es ist richtig dass der Hijab besonders
für das Regime eine hohe symbolische
Bedeutung hat aber auch für Teile der
Gesellschaft deshalb ist es
unwahrscheinlich dass das Kopftuch
komplett abgeschafft wird aber es könnte
Änderungen geben wie mit dem
kopftuchgebot umgegangen wird
ich glaube die Regierung möchte nicht
dass das Kopftuch Thema länger zu einem
großen Problem wird das ist zum Thema
einer Auseinandersetzung wird bei der es
keine Gewinner oder Verlierer geben kann
ich denke dass selbst wenn es die
Vorfälle dieser Tage nicht gäbe Irans
politisches System das Kopftuch Thema
weniger streng behandeln würde
doch die die hier demonstrieren
interessieren sich nicht für Reformen
sie wollen den Sturz des Regimes das
Irans politische Führung überhaupt zu
Reformen in der Lage sei hält der
Theologe Mohammed abtarife unmöglich als
Mitglied der Staatsführung Ende der 90er
forderte er eine Öffnung des Systems und
wurde dafür ins Gefängnis geworfen
das System ist tief in seinem Inneren
völlig korrupt und da sehr viele an
dieser Korruption teilhaben und davon
profitieren ist der Kampf vom Reformen
aussichtslos das Regime ist in seinem
Bemühen die eigene Macht zu erhalten
völlig erstarrt
alle diese Stimmen konnten wir in den
ersten Wochen der Proteste einholen wir
haben mit vielen Akteuren von beiden
Seiten gesprochen vor der Kamera aber in
vielen Fällen auch ohne Kamera und
einige wie die Frauenrechtlerin feuseher
Chemie wurden wenige Tage nach dem
Interview verhaftet das Regime versucht
öffentliche Kritik zu unterdrücken und
das mussten auch viele künstler:innen
und Sportlerinnen erfahren
wie die sportkletterin elners Reka B bei
den Asien Meisterschaften in Südkorea
tritt sie für Irans Nationalmannschaft
ohne Kopftuch an vor den Augen der Welt
diese Bilder lösen ein Erdbeben aus
in Internetforen wird sie gefeiert als
neue Heldin der Proteste in ihrer Heimat
wir drehen bei einer Kulturveranstaltung
in Teheran junge Frauen zeigen sich ganz
offen ohne Kopftuch und für viele hier
steht fest dass auch Elenas recy mit
ihrem Auftritt ein politisches Zeichen
setzen wollte
sie hat das sehr gut gemacht und ich
hoffe dass noch mehr Sportlerinnen und
Sportler so etwas tun damit wir an der
Situation etwas ändern können
doch es dauert nicht lange da tritt die
Staatsmacht an die neue Helden zu
bestrafen zumindest aber zu entzaubern
auf ihrem instagram-account erscheint
eine Entschuldigung es handle sich um
ein Missverständnis sie bedauere die
Aufregung als die tags darauf nach Iran
zurückkehrt gibt sie am Flughafen eine
gespenstische Pressekonferenz
ich musste schnell meine Schuhe und
meine Kletterausrüstung anlegen da habe
ich vergessen den richtigen Hijab
anzuziehen den ich hätte tragen sollen
so bin ich dann zur Wand gegangen und
bin geklettert
ihre Fans empfangen sie trotzdem jubelnd
und feiern ihren Mut
vielleicht werden sie die Leute wegen
dieses Dementis noch mehr lieben denn es
ist klar dass sie unter Druck gesetzt
wurde das zu sagen das wird dir
vielleicht noch mehr Sympathien
einbringen
die jungen Leute ertragen diese Lügen
des Systems nicht mehr das bekommt auch
Regierungssprecher giacomi zu spüren an
der Universität in kommen sucht er den
Dialog mit den Studenten wie er sagt
doch er wird niedergebollt
wir wollen nicht mit Mördern reden rufen
einige und immer wieder Frauen Leben
Freiheit ja auch er unterstütze diese
Ziele sagt Regierungssprecher giacomi
aber er sei hier offenbar nicht
erwünscht ihr schreit ja nur rum sagt er
und geht
sie können nicht miteinander reden und
die jungen Leute an den Universitäten
wollen es auch nicht für sie gibt es
nichts mehr zu besprechen
in Iran tobt zurzeit auch ein Propaganda
Krieg jede Seite versucht ihre Version
der Geschichte zu erzählen und ihre
Anhängerschaft zu mobilisieren die
Regierungsseite tut das über die
Staatsmedien die Protestierenden über
das Internet und die sozialen
Plattformen für sie ist das die einzige
Chance ihren Protest der Welt zu zeigen
doch einige unserer Berichte sind ihnen
zu Regime freundlich zu sagen dass die
Teilnehmerzahlen der Proteste stagnieren
oder das Politiker und geistliche
Reformen fordern oder das zwar eine
Mehrheit aber eben nicht alle den
Regimewechsel wollen für solche Aussagen
werden wir von der iranischen
auslands-opposition angegriffen für sie
sind wir Handlanger des müller-regimes
auf der anderen Seite sind wir für das
Regime das Sprachrohr der Aufwiegler aus
dem Westen jeder Bericht von uns wird
genau registriert wir werden überwacht
unsere Bewegungsfreiheit ist
eingeschränkt aus Teheran rausfahren
dürfen wir nicht Interviews mit
Protestierenden dürfen wir schon mal gar
nicht machen und im Grunde sind auch
Straßenbilder und Straßenumfragen nicht
erwünscht
doch wir müssen zeigen dass sich Frauen
in Teherans Straßen ohne Kopftuch zeigen
wir müssen auch die Seite der
Protestierenden zeigen nicht nur durch
Handyvideos es ist gefährlich für beide
Seiten trotzdem wagen wir es sprechen
Frauen auf der Straße an und schließlich
ist auch eine Demonstrantin bereit mit
uns zu reden so entsteht Ende Oktober
dieser Bericht aus Teheran
von Tag zu Tag werden es mehr Frauen
ohne Kopftuch in den Straßen Teherans
als wir eine von ihnen interviewen
wollen erkennt eine andere unser ZDF
Mikrofon und ruft auf deutsch
und Liebe Freiheit
iranische Frauen wütend und mutig wir
wollen das Gespräch fortsetzen doch
sofort hält ein Motorrad
Sicherheitskräfte beenden unser
Interview
in diesen Tagen sind es zunehmend
Aktionen zivilen Ungehorsams Graffitis
hochkonzerte auf den Straßen
regimekritische Rufer aus den Fenstern
am Abend ein Schlag auf den Turban eines
Geistlichen die Solidarität im Ausland
macht ihnen Mut
das hilft uns hundertprozentig sagt
diese junge Frau die nicht erkannt
werden will diese Aktionen helfen dass
unsere Stimmen in der ganzen Welt gehört
werden so etwas hat es bisher noch nicht
gegeben kurz nach Ausstrahlung dieses
Berichts bekam ein Team Mitglied
Arbeitsverbot einem Kameramann hatte man
vorher bereits die Pressekarte
abgenommen der Druck auf uns Vertreter
der Auslandspresse wächst je länger die
Proteste andauern
und erst recht wächst der Druck auf die
Protestbewegung der Sprecher der
zentralen Behörde für die Durchsetzung
islamischer Gesetze verkündete man werde
keinen Millimeter weichen Verstöße gegen
das kopftuchgebot würden ab jetzt nicht
mehr Geduld
es scheint als habe sich das Regime
entschieden weiter hart durchzugreifen
mit brutaler Gewalt so setzte der Chef
der Revolutionsgarden den
Protestierenden vor wenigen Tagen ein
Ultimatum
genug mit diesen Bosheiten heute ist der
letzte Tag der Proteste wagt es nicht
mehr auf die Straßen zu gehen
doch sie gehen weiter auf die Straßen
und das Regime schlägt zurück die Zahl
der Opfer steigt täglich
selbst wenn die Proteste aufhören wenn
Sie es schaffen die Sache in ein paar
Tagen zu beenden dann wird es zwar
wieder ruhig sein
aber die nächste masseamini wartet schon
um die nächste Ecke in zwei Wochen einem
Monat sechs Monaten und dann werden die
Proteste noch erbitterter noch
gewalttätiger seinen
wir sind alle Maße rufen Sie so schnell
das scheint sicher kommt Iran nicht so
gut
[Musik]